the goal of this video is to give an
overview of some terms that you will see
as we study government and they come out
of political philosophy either from the
Enlightenment or even well before the
Enlightenment some of them these ideas
are referred to in Scripture or from the
classical Greeks so let's say we have a
little community of human beings right
over here and we talked about this in
our social contract video so this right
over here is our community and so the
first idea is maybe all individuals are
endowed with some type of what we could
call natural rights that just by being a
human being you should have these rights
and once again these go back to the
Enlightenment or well be it well before
the Enlightenment even to something like
scripture and some notions of natural
rights might be well the right to your
life the right to Liberty the right to
the pursuit of happiness pursuit of
happiness those should sound very
familiar and we're going to study these
ideas more in future videos the right to
have your own personal the right to have
your own personal property now in the
social contract video we talked well in
theory if you don't have any type of
overarching enforcement body or some
type of code of contact code of conduct
some people might also say well I'm
gonna give myself some other rights
maybe the right to seek revenge maybe
the right to imprison in prison folks
revenge I could say also to punish if I
think someone has wronged me or if I
even don't like them that could revenge
or punishment the right to take property
take property and we clearly see a
conflict here because these things that
I'm writing in this pink color if I
assume to have these rights that would
allow me to infringe on other people's
natural rights and so the idea behind
social contract is well what if we as a
society we decide to give up these
as an individual and we give them to
something we call a government so we'll
give these rights to a government and in
exchange the government should protect
my other rights not only these natural
rights but maybe I have other rights
that I will expect my government to
protect and that notion is what we talk
about in the social contract video as
well social contract which is a nice
term to know we're giving up rights to
the government in exchange for the
government doing things for us but that
still leaves a very big question what
type of government do we have even in
that social contract video people said
well maybe we don't need a full
government maybe just all of us can
agree not to do these things to each
other and if someone does we can come up
with some policies of what would be the
punishment at cetera et cetera and then
maybe we could get some people to
enforce it just to make sure that people
know it's going to happen well even in
that very primitive state you are
starting to create some form of a
government now if we think about larger
communities of people the predominant
form of government that we've seen
throughout most of human history has
been a monarchy where you have some type
of a king or a queen or an emperor who
rules over a country who rules over a
nation who rules over a state now with
the birth of the United States you start
having a major country with an alternate
form of government and that's a notion
of a democracy democracy which you can
imagine is another important term to
know and this comes from the classical
Greeks during the Golden Age of Athens
you have what was first referred to as a
democracy that was just a city-state
with the United States you start having
a democracy for a fairly large country
even when it was formed at the time
obviously the United States is now much
larger and the core idea behind a
democracy is that you don't have a
monarch who rules who is the sovereign
you have the people who rule the people
are the sovereign and so this is another
term that you will see
you have popular popular sovereignty
sovereignty Randi it's a fancy word but
sovereign is just well what rules over
it you see the term right over here to
reign
what rules over things and here you have
the people are ruling and that's what's
happening here in a democracy so here
the people the people are ruling now in
either case of a monarchy or a democracy
you have to ask the question of well
regardless of who's ruling can they just
rule on anything arbitrarily if all of
these people decide to vote on taking
maybe someone else's rights
maybe this person's rights right over
here is that okay or if this monarch
wants to take this person's rights is
that okay and so because of that fear
that either with a monarchy or even with
a democracy in a democracy you might
have the majority to rule to do
something to a minority that is not so
good that starts to infringe on their
natural rights in order to avoid that
you have this notion of limited
government limited government which is
this idea that regardless of who's
ruling whether it's a monarch or the
people you need to put some laws in
place maybe put a constitution in place
that very explicitly states well what
are the powers of the government what
rice as a government have and what
rights do the people have and so you
could implement a constitution and you
can actually do it in either case
Constitution Yen laws of which the
Constitution helps set up and if you're
talking about a monarchy that is limited
by a constitution so if you have a king
or a queen but even they can't just rule
anything that's often known as a
constitutional monarchy but when you
have a democracy that is constrained
that has limited government by these
laws that is protecting the rights of
people we refer to this as a republic
or republicanism so this this is another
good word republicanism this is the
limited government and republicanism are
often strongly associated with it with
each other and that's why the United
States today and many countries that
have actually in fact modeled themselves
after the United States refer to
themselves as democratic republics
and so with just these terms you have
been well-armed
to better study not just the US
government but governments in general
and in future videos we will see how
some of the founding documents of the
United States like the Declaration of
Independence like the United States
Constitution really embody these ideas
you